Eric are there I oh used on the street
at this time no Tom the only things on
the street of the pamphlets left over
from the weekend campaign all key for
the no side they're the winners of
course almost more than 61 percent in
the referendum and nine would be the yes
vote they are the losers this morning
Tom the big question is who's going to
be the next finance minister as Bonnie
said moments ago Yanis varoufakis
unexpectedly resigned the question we're
trying to figure out here on the ground
is did Votto farkas resign himself take
himself out of the game or did syphilis
the Prime Minister push him out there is
a lot to be read between the lines here
I would not take anything you see as
certainly not vital fact his blog at
face value Tom right very quickly here
eric is cereza gain power with this vote
is a left left in Athens stronger this
Monday morning I'd say almost
unquestionably but Tom that strength may
last ever so briefly remember that this
is the same party the same prime
minister that has promised the Greek
people tomorrow the banks will open if
the banks do not open tomorrow and all
of a sudden depositors face the prospect
however unlikely of haircuts the
prospect that they may lose their life
savings to some kind of a bail-in effort
that support is going to evaporate very
quickly may be gone in a matter of days
tom Eric sheryn Anthes you'll join us at
the top of the seven o'clock hour
Brendan we have Hans Nichols in Berlin
as well Hans we've got two pieces of
news out right this minute one is of
course Alexis tsipras had a phone call
with Michelle Francois Hollande of
France but the other is Merkel's
spokesperson says miracles rescue
policies haven't failed that to me says
she's worried about her legacy is is is
it France or is it Germany's concern
with its legacy that's going to keep
this whole thing together well for
Greece's sake they better hope it's
Germany's concern and Uggla Merkel is
concerned that she cares about her
legacy the question is what's her legacy
is their legacy building and reaffirming
a strong eurozone or is it keeping
Greece in the euro zone by breaking
those rules
the discussion here seems to be almost
uniformly and we've you know we've heard
members of parliament all morning we've
just heard from the government
spokespeople that a rules can't be
broken and B you can't have any
unconditional money it's headed out the
door to Athens because you may not get
it back mahasen order for the German
parliament actually approve any new deal
they've got to come back this summer any
sign that might happen until we have an
official even request from Greece to the
eurozone group which they'll be meeting
this time tomorrow that's several steps
down the way I mean we've got to do so
many things before you can think about
an emergency summit in Parliament not
the least of which is having a bill
passed the house path Parliament in
Athens otherwise you're not gonna have a
vote back here let alone a summons
bringing the German ha parliamentarians
back from their vacation I'm snickles
Erik schatzker thank you so much